Qu'est-ce que c'est que ça ?
Vos nouvelles tenues sont magnifiques, les gars !
C'est quoi tout ce bordel ?
Le rouge est ta nouvelle couleur Numéro 2 !
Désolé les gars.
C'est débile !
Voyez ça comme un travail d'équipe.
La clé est de rester subtile.
Voyez ça comme un cadeau "spécial Deadpool" pour vos  659 millions de fans dans le monde entier.
"Joueur du mois"
"Effort maximum"
Nan mais c'est quoi ça ?
Pour qui il se prend ?
Qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Ils ne portent même pas les genouillères officielles Deadpool.
Je sais qu'ils ont pas besoin de genouillères pour jouer
mais ils en ont besoin maintenant.
J'aurai la tête de José pour ça.
José !
Vous savez, quand on fait une suite, il faut doubler les promos
sinon vous vous faîtes battre par Avengers Infinity War.